okay so when riot announced that they
were working on a first-person shooter
back in October people were both like
god damn christmas came early and what
the hell is this thing well yesterday
they dropped a bunch of new information
on us we've got an official name a
release date our first significant look
at some gameplay and a better
understanding of just what the hell this
thing is
so let's break it all down
[Music]
so if you want to hear our perspective
on these big new game releases and all
the information that come with them
there's a few different things you can
do namely subscribing to the channel and
you know liking the video all of that
helps us understand what you want to see
from us okay so let's start with what we
know first off the name riots
first-person shooter codenamed project a
is in fact called valoran which I mean
it sounds like a bathroom air freshener
but it's a name I guess and it's coming
a lot sooner than expected like this
summer soon
[Music]
Florent is a free-to-play 5v5 tactical
shooter with gameplay revolving around
plant and defuse much like csgo
but here it's not called a bomb it's
called a spike and well this change from
bomb to spike might seem like a small
thing to me it says that riot is
avoiding the terrorists vs. Counter
Terrorist imagery that certain sponsors
have had a problem with when it comes to
csgo in the past
according to a sneek media preview that
polygon god there's allegedly going to
be eight characters at launch each with
their own set of powers and ultimate
abilities kind of sort of like overwatch
riot is also making a big deal about 128
tick rate servers great netcode and anti
cheat software built from the ground up
now if you're a fan of csgo some of the
things I just mentioned might sound
familiar and that's because there are
all issues that csgo has had in the past
right server lag hackers I mean you get
the point and based on all of the
language that ride is using it seems
like they're trying to muscle in on csgo
scorner and I mean that literally like
check out this line from their press
release throughout the lorentz
development we wanted to uphold the
fundamental values of a competitive
tactical shooter precise shooting lethal
gunplay and strategic execution you
standing on my liver state come on
Tukey y-you was resting now based on
everything I just said how close is this
thing really to see us go or even
Rainbow six siege okay now I was talking
to one of our resident csgo heads Colin
and a few other people in the office the
other day and here's some of the
thoughts opinions and ideas that we've
been throwing around about the game so
far right off the bat the graphics kind
of look like ass and while that might
sound like a negative it could actually
be a good thing because it means that
Wright might be focusing on optimizing
for performance I mean look we're not
gonna get that optimal framerate if we
got particle effects and insanely
complicated character models running
around right which you know is the exact
reason why I can play csgo on my MacBook
at work now when you look at valoran the
first thing you'll notice is that yet
these guys have guns but they also got a
bunch of magical powers and [ __ ] and
some of these powers well they're
basically like utility from say csgo
for example there's a fire guy who can
throw fireballs that essentially act as
molly's there's this other character
with wind abilities and she can lob like
this smoke cloud which is essentially a
smoke grenade be faster one enemy
remaining okay can we just pause for a
second did that character have voice
lines for like every action if that's
true I better be able to turn that [ __ ]
off because that's gonna get old real
quick and then that wind character has
this ability to send themselves up in
the air which I guess is like some weird
self boost thing and they'll be able to
peak from like vertical angles and [ __ ]
you know maybe valoran will have its own
Olaf boost one day he sees them now
they're straight heads up man
Smith's looking confused and dazed then
on the other hand there's some character
abilities that go way beyond the utility
you would see and see us go like there's
one character for example whose ultimate
ability allows you to literally
resurrect a teammate now the words
resurrection and like hardcore
first-person shooters
doesn't really jive in my mind Mercy's
res ability literally broke overwatch
for a while have we not learned anything
nice now if you've spent any time
playing csgo
you know that the economy understanding
it and using it to your advantage adds a
beautiful level of depth to the game so
what do we know about the Lawrence
economy well we do know that you're
gonna have to buy weapons armor and
abilities which is a step in the right
direction now the economy is split into
actual money buys you armor and weapons
then there's these points which you can
collect throughout the map and you gain
from getting kills and defusing the
spike that allow you to buy abilities
the abilities menu located below has its
own currency your champions utility can
only be purchased with points which you
can earn for performing certain actions
some abilities have multiple charges
such as jets smoke grenades and Phoenix
is careful and there is a maximum that
you can purchase at any one time there's
rumors of a round last bonus system but
riot has yet to confirm that also from
the gameplay that we've seen during the
buy phase CTS or defenders can Traverse
up to half the map and get to site that
much faster which that's certainly
something different you know what else
is a nice touch there seems to be a
request a weapon feature gone are the
days where you're asking for a Buy and
three dudes throw opps at you okay let's
talk about those characters a little bit
more and like I said there's gonna be
eight at launch there's a dude who can
basically insta rotate anywhere on the
map with his teleportal there's another
guy who's got floor traps tripwires and
a spy camera that he can attach to walls
my point is is that it seems like riot
is taking aspects of first-person
shooters that add layers and layers of
depth and turning them into well
clickable abilities can't properly throw
a smoke there's an ability to point
click on the map and a smoke screen
drops down can't properly execute a
boost with a teammate well like we said
there's a guy that does that on a more
positive note apparently the game feels
great to play and if you're a csgo head
well you just breathe a giant sigh of
relief a big part of the reason why we
love csgo so much is because of that
tight and crispy feel that the source
engine has blessed us with and if guys
like Henry G believe that valoran can
get anywhere near that feeling well
that's a positive sign now obviously we
still have a bunch of questions for
example we have no idea what the hell is
going on with the eSports scene but with
this latest info dump we do have a
better understanding of what valoran is
shaping up to look like and with that
summer release date right around the
corner
well we won't have to wait long to find
out we're not gonna get that optimal
framerate if we got [ __ ] insane
particle complex things and I know we're
not gonna get that optimal framerate I
don't want my framerate is not optimal
there's the [ __ ] end boy god damn